let's show the people
out in stores august 17th wherever you
get your books
you wrote a book
i wrote a book can you believe it i'm an
author
have you processed that at all is it
weird to hold the physical item very
weird and i'm very proud and of course
you're gonna love this story bryce
because there's this part you know the
pictures which i love a book with
pictures this one of your this hair is
wild little dorinda cincala there with
the hair
of like i don't know i had it hannah has
that hair and you want to hear the word
thing i was born with that that's wild
but this is the one i love the one with
the perm that's a home
that's a perm i did at home and
i forgot i forgot i had permanent my
hair so about i was supposed to stay in
for like
eight minutes like 25 minutes later my
head was on fire and my friend says to
me are you still supposed to have that i
was like oh my god
that is the product of
a bad firm
i went with it of course you have always
been you i think what i loved about
reading the book but it fills in a lot
of the gaps that we never got to learn
about
on roni we learn about jordana cincala
to dorinda lynch to dorinda medley to
just
derinda
that's right do you find yourself being
all of those women some of those women
some of the time
who's at the forefront right now at this
stage in your life well you know what's
interesting it's funny you say that
because during covet i was with
obviously it was backup of bluestone
manor and i became so doing this in
college it was like the concord back to
youth when i'm back in and massachusetts
i'm definitely doing the cincala when i
am with hannah i am mom she doesn't want
to know hear or talk about me being the
real housewife in new york city in fact
she'll sometimes say to me can we just
be mom today but i think what i am today
is a much more peaceful combination of
all of
a them of the book is that your life
resets itself about every six years
do you feel the book is the close of the
last chapter or the start of the next
that's a good question because i don't
think you ever fully close last chapters
because you keep on carrying on lessons
from each chapter you win but it's
definitely there it's definitely there's
a beginning there is something going on
for me right now we're just all things
have come together i don't know if that
would have happened if i didn't stop
and just sort of reset a bit you open
the book
on the pause we will not use fired
because that word andy apparently
doesn't like the pause why was that the
place to start this story because that's
where i was
and if not for that i probably wouldn't
have had the sort of time dedication or
interest in writing the book
so
it it really
was a pause what did you learn about
yourself in re-examining your own life
what's the takeaway for you
i'm pretty strong what was interesting
when i had to write about richard's
death was you know by the time you guys
met me as an audience
he had already passed obviously for a
while and you know it's his 10-year
anniversary this year and you know but
people don't real yeah can you imagine
wacky
i don't even know if richard would know
me you know what i mean i've got such a
different life i would love to have a
cocktail with them and tell them about
me today wouldn't that be interesting
yeah but i think that you know by the
time i started talking about richard
openly i had already i had restored him
in my mind so
the process i had to go and go through
was no longer part of my story or
something i i revisited or hannah
revisited we were kind of like oh my god
oh my god that was scary i didn't want
to hurt his children and i didn't want
to hurt hannah even ralph loved richard
so much i remember ralph said one of the
most beautiful things to richard uh
days before he passed he said i want you
to know richard i promise you the day
our daughter gets married i'll be on one
side and you'll be on the other that's
beautiful
so for ralph to say that it was just
i was like we did this right we we made
it nice here yeah you made it nice yeah
to live up to the title because i've
decorated it
i mean it's nice is there anyone in your
life in particular that you are
nervous to have read the book no
i definitely definitely just didn't do
it on the cuffs like i talked to my
brothers i talk to my old boyfriends i
talk to my parents so all the people who
are kind of named in this have an idea
of what might be included there's not
going to be any surprises to those
people and i haven't said anything that
really isn't no there's i mean there's
fun and wild reveals like you almost
being the victim of a serial killer in
this but there's nothing terrible
there's can you imagine that can you
imagine that but he always creeped me
out
so if i say anything to people if that
inner feeling that sixth sense my mother
calls it the holy spirit
it's sort of something i i don't know if
it's your your my mother would say it's
your guardian angel people would say
anthropological just like an animal you
know if an animal like things
and i had a gut instinct i was like huh
this person kind of rubs me wrong
and i was right well i would say it's
also a theme of the book to follow your
gut when i don't follow my intuition
when i don't follow that feeling like
this is right and i go against that
grain it always
fails for me one moment in which you
followed your intuition was to turn down
the original offer to become a real
housewife of new york city
what wait you know what that's wrong
there was never an offer that was okay
we were all talking about conversation
yeah well it was all on the upper east
side you know it was going around
everywhere that they were you know the
show was coming out and yeah i was
always sort of someone in the mix just
like a lot of the girls because we all
knew each other i think that's one of
the reasons why
it works so easily for me you know
listen people don't realize and i i have
said this million times anyone that says
anything about housewives takes some
very brave women to put themselves out
there like that so i um knew that
because i watched you know
there's no getting away from it
i'm not always right but i'm never wrong
in the discussion of the pause you open
it with at the time not understanding it
not getting the decision that was made
do you get it now and are you
appreciative of it now do i get it now
in what way like do you get why you were
put on pause
not really
i don't i'm not upset about it anymore i
was sad about it in the beginning i
didn't but i never really i didn't
personally fully understand it you know
people have done
much worse or than me on the show and
had this sort of resurrection moment and
come back people have you know had
horrible seasons of the resurrection
season and we could name them off within
my cast and many others
um and i also thought the time i
couldn't for me bryce the thing that was
interesting is that with the timing
because i i was under depression but i
because of the year that i had and the
flood and the house coming back and the
renovation and the
breaking up with john i thought
the next year would be sort of that
would be the reset well and the timing
was so odd because we found out before
even the reunions had finished airing so
it just it was this weird space to live
in of like we were watching a ghost on
tv almost which i think was upsetting to
people yeah
and i think also too you know i was
under i thought i was planning this
whole thing for a lot of the covert
activities to happen at blue stone manor
because blue stone matter
what it was to me had become such a
character on the show right
so i was like wow they're kind of
getting rid of me and bluestone manor
but you know what i think you know i i
think that in the long run it opened up
a lot of opportunities i would not been
able to write this book because or i
would have written a brooke book that
would be oh just right i think it's like
you said in my question of you start on
the pause and that's the place you were
i think that was the perfect place to
start because it kind of set the tone
for
a time to be reflective it was very
fortuitous for me because of timing yeah
who wanted who wanted to be filming
during covet anyway
it's tough
the fans have been tough on this season
there's a lot of discussion about where
the show goes enough season 14 if they
came to you and said
here's the apple back
do you take it you never say never right
you know i'm always open to
opportunities i think this season's not
over yet i think there's probably
you know the season needs to end and
settle and then who knows what's going
to happen over the next three four
months i know
no conversations have happened as of yet
no no and they never do and also too i
think it's an ever-changing thing isn't
it yeah and you know you're in the
business yeah
they they don't make people have this
bizarre idea that they make these
decisions months and months before right
it's months and months after that's why
but then there are the curveballs like
your paws that then make people go wait
how does this work because the timing of
that didn't line up with
the traditional timing yeah i asked andy
cohen recently about you know what does
the future of the show look like he
said it's probably the cast that we have
plus some like think back to season
seven which your first that cast of like
eight women you know that's i think the
vision for the next season well i think
the audience would love that i do think
there's listen i think people are very
reminiscent about
the old cass yeah and i think it's great
to have new blood as well
and i think it's great to have blue
stone manor back have you been watching
this season or have you been kind of
like you know what
i watch them all okay you have not given
it up have you ever
been watching it i watched them before
and i watch them after but it's always
going to be like you know you know when
you first got out of college and you're
you're out of college you're doing great
at your job but then someone says oh my
god i'll call you after spring break and
you're like i miss spring break
so
i'm not going to be that person that's
like no no i may you know of course you
always have those moments because
there's incredible camaraderie
it is i did it for six years my heart of
heart tells me you'll be back i did at
the beginning of the season i asked
ramona would you welcome her back say
season 14 if she came back around
i don't know if she's ready to come back
i was like i don't i don't think that's
true ramona i don't know why ramona
would say that maybe she's afraid i'm
gonna come back you know i don't have
first of all ramona doesn't know me
anymore ramona hasn't contacted me at
all and i think if she's saying things
like that it's more out of fear than it
is other i need you know anything honest
we just don't talk
and i think she has her own stuff to
worry about
this is true all right so in the book a
theme is
live life with no regrets
you know even if you
didn't like how something went or
something you did you can take a lesson
away from it and i just wonder and um
you know you say you don't have any
regrets about housewives either but is
there any moment that maybe the outcome
would stay the same but would you have
handled any particular moment
differently well i think there is not a
housewife that comes out of a season
that doesn't have a regret i feel very
bad for what happened with tinsley
because i could see the writing on the
wall added myself to
sir i dumbness have communicated better
it was just you know
it's where i was at that time i was not
in a great great place and i tried to
communicate that to i think
the girls at the beginning when we were
at the winery i am scared every day
of what
just i know everybody thinks i'm so
strong and so tough and so able and so
this and be the the the anchor for
everyone's boat
but sometimes i want to be the boat
every once in a while and just anchor to
someone and the thing that i think i
learned from that is everybody has to be
on the cross at some point and i really
felt like a couple people that i thought
would be helpful and supportive during
that time weren't
and i was really struggling last year in
the theme of your life resetting itself
every six years and entering these new
phases what do you think the next six
look like for you is there another book
more tv romance what's kind of on the
you know well i talked about i i talked
about it in the book it's fair you know
you just can't you think you know what's
going to happen and then it doesn't but
i think
i'm very happy with all these new
partnerships i've done i mean i've loved
my nutrisystem partnership i lost 16
pounds wow that's amazing
congratulations yeah right i mean my god
when they called me up and said oh my
god it's you know
i was both
so honored and insulted at the same time
i was like thank you but why yeah
but
[Music]
thought about that it's like it's so
flattering this big corporation wants to
work with you but also they're like
calling you not you know the ideal body
type but i had i i just you know i just
let it all hang out i mean once i put on
those elasticated pants it was over
we can all relate we can all relate
no i just so i was so happy that i when
i get inside of it and i really lost to
16 pounds it just built my confidence up
and now it's like a way of life and then
we're going to do this airbnb the airbnb
thing is wild to me dorinda so i know
it's just it's two one night stays it's
a little quick situation while you're on
your book tour but are you concerned
hold on a second you know what i said to
someone the other day in the interview
it's two one night stands
it kind of i mean
but are you at all concerned about
people like rooting through the the
manor and looking through your stuff or
it's kind of
because here's the thing it's very as
you can imagine it's very um
like they're not going to be in my
bedroom you know there's certain
limitations it's crazy it's kind of
graceland it's you stay in certain areas
of the house okay exactly it's and it's
you know it's all very vetted you're
worried about people coming here for
like a short overnight stay when i've
allowed the housewives to come here for
six years okay fair fair plane that is a
very fair
[Laughter]
point i think about that
on that though where books are sold
[Music]
you